madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues chers amis
pour la liberté de danser dans la rue
pour la peur au moment de s'embrasser
pour nos mères et nos soeurs disparus
pour changer les mentalités arriérées
pour lui désir d'une vie ordinaire femme
vie liberté pour la liberté
c'est quelque paroles de baroyer cette
chanson devenue un symbole du peuple qui
se soulève me bouleverse parce que même
si nous ne parlons pas la même langue le
langage de l'espoir et de la liberté et
bien universel
et c'est celui de la sororité de la
fraternité de l'humanité qui nous
rassemble aujourd'hui je salue la
nécessité la nécessaire résolution que
propose notre collègue Adrien Gomy et le
remercie pour son engagement et cette
initiative je suis fière ce jour de me
tenir devant vous pour ce moment
d'importance pour porter la voix du
groupe démocrate à ce propos oui mes
chers collègues je suis touchée qui ne
le serait pas devant les images nous
parvenons devant ce courage quotidien
pour affronter la violence les
intimidations les arrestations la mort
je prononce le nom de Marsa Amini ici 22
ans arrêté parce qu'elle n'aurait mal
porté son voile passez à tabac par la
police des mœurs elle ne survécut pas à
ses blessures elle est une martyre le
symbole puissant de ce combat pour la
liberté depuis sa mort le 16 septembre
2022 les manifestations ont commencé
dans le Kurdistan iranien avant de se
propager à Téhéran et rapidement à tout
le pays les femmes ont été initiatrices
de ce mouvement bravant les menaces et
tous les interdits désormais toutes les
générations s'unissent et luttes la
diaspora se fait le relais de cette
lutte dans le monde entier et nous
permet de comprendre et d'agir je sais
que certains sont présents aujourd'hui
et je tiens à les saluer et à les
remercier
dans le pays l'importance du soulèvement
se caractérise aussi par les grèves qui
ont pu avoir lieu comme dans le secteur
pétrolier clé de l'économie mais aussi
par les enseignants qui souhaitaient
dénoncer la violence commise à l'égard
des enfants les marchands considérés
comme la base sociale du régime ont
également fermé leur magasin du 15 au 17
novembre un acte fort il nous le disent
partout désormais sur les réseaux six
notes protestent this is révolution
depuis le Mouvement Vert de 2009 et les
manifestations de 2018 c'est une période
historique que construit le peuple
iranien oui
cet historique pour la liberté mais quel
chemin sanglant et dramatique pour y
parvenir
prenons conscience de la violence subie
par les Iraniennes et les Iraniens
environ 15000 arrestations
500 personnes tuées dont 60 enfants tués
par balle Abou portant
certains frappés à mort comme le relate
Amnesty International
Mona 8 ans
j’abert 12 ans
Nima Sarina Yasser ils avaient 16 ans
resa 22 ans Hammad 24 ans cette jeunesse
est particulièrement visée car elle
porte l'espoir et l'énergie de tout un
peuple chacun de ces visages disparu
nous rappelle que derrière les chiffres
c'est une amie une sœur un fils un père
qui ne reverra plus jamais les siens
même à l'autre bout du monde chaque mort
chaque violence nous concerne en tant
que femme en tant que mère j'ai une
pensée émue pour ses disparus
injustement arraché à leur famille dans
ce monde parfois incertain notre
humanité reste le bien le plus précieux
refuser la liberté au peuple un jour le
peuple la reprendra écrivait Émile Zola
ce devoir de solidarité est une évidence
notre histoire en France pays des Droits
humains nous oblige nous devons mesurer
que le droit sacré de la liberté
d'expression notre droit de sortir dans
la ruée de manifester notre droit à la
pensée critique sont les droits pour
lesquels des milliers de personnes
luttent aujourd'hui en Iran ainsi en
tant que représentant du peuple français
cette proposition de résolution affirme
à toutes et à tous notre soutien au
peuple iranien dans cette quête pour la
justice pour la liberté nous soutenons
son droit de manifester effectivement
d'exprimer librement ses revendications
et ses opinions nous dénonçons les
tortures les répressions et toutes les
violences injustement subies je vous
remercie cette résolution mes chers
collègues est un message de force et
d'espoir que nous aiderons peuple
iranien ou qu'il se trouve et c'est avec
notre soutien le plus entier que le
groupe démocrate votera cette résolution
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]